[Music]
the golden knights continue their
preseason play tonight in colorado
taking on the avalanche that's right but
heading into tonight's match up everyone
everyone is talking about goaltender
robin leonard and his recent statements
made on twitter over the weekend eight
sports kevin martin joins us live in
studio with more as he addressed the
media for the very first time today hey
kevin well thanks christian robin
leonard is a long time mental health
advocate who has been open about his
bipolar disorder disorder and his own
struggles off the ice and this past
saturday the vgk goaltender took to
twitter and made several accusations
including that many teams give players
drugs without doctors consent the nhl
and nhlpa reached out to leonard to set
up an interview which they've had since
then leonard who addressed the media for
the first time since saturday said it
was a cry for help
it's not something i enjoy this is
incredibly tough
but
for a long time i've been trying to
to be heard and to implement some change
not publicly
it hasn't happened
and what happened over the weekend
was a cry for help in the end of the day
it brought the conversation and brought
everyone to the table and the rest will
be buying closed doors and it will not
be in the public eye
leonard said he is very encouraged about
the talks they had and will have moving
forward entering his 13th season in the
nhl he understands there will be
backlash and believes it's worth it to
try to implement change adding he did
not tweet to seek any attention saying
quote if he can help one percent i'm
really happy about that christian